hold up is that a tamagotchi are we in
the 2000s what makes may turn into the
adorable ravaging red panda stay tuned
for nostalgia fluff and more things only
adults notice and turning red but be
warned there's major spoilers
ahead turning red starts with an
extended sequence in which mei
introduces herself by speaking directly
to the camera while breaking the fourth
wall isn't unheard of in films these
days we're most familiar with people
talking directly to the camera when it's
the camera in their smartphones as a
result it makes sense that viewers may
initially think turning red takes place
in the present day however there are
many things about the movie that
indicate it actually takes place around
20 years ago while none of the kids
carry smartphones there are other
details that make the time period even
more evident one of the first hints
about when the movie takes place happens
when mei's friend miriam gives her a cd
of a 1999 concert of their favorite boy
band 4 town not only were boy bands like
nsync and the backstreet boys huge
around the turn of the century cds was
still the preferred method on which to
listen to and own music by the end of
the film the era specifically been
identified as 2002 but until then small
details offer clues about its time
period
while kids learn about puberty in health
class until you go through it you can't
really understand what it's like as a
result teenagers and adults are likely
to relate to the film's depiction of
early adolescence and realize just how
perfectly the story encapsulates the
experience adolescence involves physical
and emotional changes and made turning
into a red panda speaks specifically to
the emotional turmoil of this time in
life before adolescence children are
perfectly happy spending time with their
parents and letting them dictate how
they should be and what they should do
starting in early adolescence though
children start becoming more interested
in their friends opinions than their
parents plus they start having all sorts
of urges they can't explain may
experiences all of this in dramatic
fashion she wants to remain the perfect
daughter in her mother's eyes so she
starts to hide things from her yes at
the same time her mother's desire to
protect is starting to feel stifling
this leads to a whole raft of emotions
that are pushing her in several
directions at once nicely summing up the
fraught transition from young child to
budding adolescents
the first time mae turns into a red
panda it's in response to a nightmare so
when she walks into the bathroom and
looks at herself in the mirror she
reacts with horror mei's parents can
hear her distressed from the kitchen
while they're eating breakfast leading
mae's worried mother ming to venture to
the bathroom door to find out what's
wrong at first ming assumes her daughter
must be sick but soon she realizes
something more unusual is going on
wait
is it
that
did the
did the red peony bloom no
adults will know ming is wondering
whether may have started menstruating
however children are likely to be just
as confused as may whose response to her
mother is less than convincing
when mae introduces herself at the
beginning of turning red she makes a
point of showing off a round pink
accessory on a keychain attached to the
strap of her backpack while children may
not know what it is adults will
recognize it as a tamagotchi a toy that
was especially popular in the late 90s
and early 2000s while the graphics and
the models from the early 2000s were
rudimentary kids often got very attached
to their tamagotchi tamagotchi has still
made today but they're nowhere near as
ubiquitous as they once were plus more
advanced technology means their graphics
are more sophisticated they can connect
to other tamagotchi and you can even
take pictures with them mei's tamagotchi
doesn't have nearly that level of
interactivity but even though the movie
doesn't put too fine a point on it it
seems she's done a good job of taking
care of her digital pet
when mae turns into a red panda she
grows to be twice her normal height and
substantially wider yet something adults
will pick up on is that may's
fantastical size doesn't make sense if
she's truly taking on the guys of a red
panda that's because red pandas are
fairly small with adults growing to be
only a bit bigger than a pet cat so
although may takes on the basic look of
a red panda with a red fur and white
accents on her face and ears if she
looks like a real-life red panda should
actually get smaller not larger this
gets especially ridiculous when ming
lets out a red panda that stums through
downtown toronto of course the magic
that causes mei's family to turn into
red pandas could be blamed for this
especially since it seems the size of
maize and ming's red pandas is
proportional to the big emotions they're
feeling nonetheless even though mae is
adorable as a red panda making her very
popular with her classmates the real
life red panda's diminutive size is one
of the things that arguably makes it
even more adorable
turning red focuses on the
mother-daughter relationship between mae
and ming yet there's another
mother-daughter relationship that also
plays a role in the story the
relationship between ming and her mother
mei's grandmother when grandma learns
that mae's red panda has appeared she
travels across the country with ming
sisters to help with the problem when
she arrives both children and adults
will notice that one of grandma's most
defining features is a prominent red
scar across her eyebrow no one mentions
how she got the scar but adults will
realize a small moment in the film
subtly sheds light on what's happened
when mei's grandmother goes to talk to
her alone she mentions that she and ming
used to be close like mingamer that is
until ming's red panda came out and
ruined their relationship
you are your mother's whole world meimei
i know you do what's right if you notice
her grandmother briefly touches her scar
it's a fleeting moment but it seems to
indicate that when ming's red panda
appeared her emotions were so out of
control that at one point she scratched
her mother leaving her with a permanent
reminder of what happened
when mei initially turns into a red
panda it's awkward and scary she's much
bigger so she can jump farther and climb
higher but she frequently miscalculates
her landings and falls and stumbles as a
result later on she becomes more
comfortable with her new form and is
able to dance and jump around while
switching from panda to human at will
it's a cool party trick but for the most
part nothing more yet during the climax
of the film when mae decides she
urgently needs to join her friends at
the 4 town concert her red panda form
seems to endow her with super powers mae
bounds over rooftops as the panda
periodically switching back to human
only to leap off another building as she
switches back again then when she
reaches a concert venue she leaps
through the open retractable roof sees
her friends in the crowd and manages to
propel herself so she lands right next
to them it's something many of the most
seasoned superheroes would have trouble
pulling off
oh no
no
[Music]
kids will love the animated antics but
adults will be left scratching their
heads about how her abilities became so
extreme so quickly
turning red makes it clear that mei is
the apple of ming's eye she sees me as
the perfect daughter and when we meet
mei she's doing everything in her power
to ensure she lives up to her mother's
impressions yet mei is also starting to
forge her own identity apart from her
mother and her overwhelming expectations
so when ming's mother calls and ming
responds with anguish and then cowards
as her mother criticizes her over the
phone adults will realize that ming is
heading down a similar path with mei
later in the film when ming's mother
tells me that she ming used to be closed
performing's red panda emerged this
perception is reinforced just like her
mother ming wants made to stay exactly
as she is but mae is growing up whether
she likes it or not if ming remains
overprotective as mae gets older mae
will soon feel like her mother is
suffocating her just like ming seem to
with her mother although she's unaware
of it ming is recreating the same kind
of relationship with mei that she has
with her mother the kind where the pair
will still love one another but will
never be as close again
i hurt her
who
my mom
i got so angry
the plot of turning red hinges on me
becoming a red panda and the havoc she
causes because of it however the rules
around what triggers her to change forms
are never made especially clear the
movie vaguely indicates that any strong
emotion will bring out the panda which
means as long as mei stays calm she
remains human while initially it appears
that only strong negative emotions cause
the change later when may starts
changing at will it seems that panda may
respond to strong positive emotions as
well yet when she discovers that
thinking of her friends enables me to
keep her panda in it seems perhaps this
isn't the case if that weren't enough
mae is told that the ritual performed on
the night of the red moon is her one
chance to get rid of the panda but if
you notice when she's in trouble her
mother grandma and aunts all smash the
trinkets that hold their pandas and once
again take on red panda form when mae is
safe they once again suppress their red
pandas through the ritual which suggests
that if she wants it mae should have a
second chance to use the ritual to let
go of her panda at a later time as well
throughout the history of film and
television there have been characters
that transform from one form to another
and they've all dealt with the issue of
what's happened so the characters closed
differently
my clothes don't fit in most dracula
films for example the master vampire
isn't clothed as a bat but he's fully
clothed in evening wear when he turns
back into human form meanwhile on the tv
show the incredible hulk david banner
famously loses his shirt when he becomes
the hulk but somehow his shorts manage
to shrink and expand as his form gets
bigger and smaller it's some serious
fabric witchcraft
at last
satan himself has come to face me
adults who have been sensitized to such
details by a lifetime of watching
productions like these are more likely
than kids to notice that in turning red
may stays fully clothed when she's human
and has those clothes poof away as soon
as her red panda fur comes out this is
understandable given this as a family
film still it could have been fun to see
mae's red panda form wearing her skirts
and sweaters
the boy band 4 town is essential to the
story of turning red during the late 90s
and early 2000s tweens and teens went as
gaga over the backstreet boys and nsync
as me and her friends do over the boys
of 4 town the movie perfectly captures
how these bands served as a way for
early adolescent girls to bond express
themselves and experience their first
crushes in a relatively safe way
in fact the film showcases exactly what
made these groups so appealing by
styling them as non-threatening pretty
boys they come across as cool and
creative and their songs suggest that if
they ever decide to commit to you that
only love you and they love you
completely the film even features three
original songs written by billy eilish
and phineas o'connell which mimicked the
simple but catchy tunes that boy bands
are known for and made them popular over
the years any adult who spend time as a
tween swooning over a boy band or
dancing with friends for their music
will instantly recognize her experience
in the depiction of four town
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one